[Music]
sony spider-verse is growing fast and
part of that expanding family is a
little movie about a highly
impressionable pile of alien goo who
finds a humanoid buddy and changes his
life
venom was pulled straight from the pages
of marvel's most 1990s comic books and
true comic fans were scouring
every frame for easter eggs so what did
we find john jameson astronaut
within the first few moments of venom we
see a spaceship piloted by some
ill-fated members of the life foundation
crash to earth
as local rescue workers dig through the
wreckage they find an astronaut they
call jameson while there's no more
context given about who this guy might
be there's only one astronaut named
jameson in marvel comics
john jameson the son of daily bugle
publisher and occasional new york city
mayor jay jonah jameson john spends some
time in the comics as the mighty man
wolf
and later star god seeing manwolf appear
in sony's rumored morbius movie would be
a halloween treat better than a bowl of
unguarded king-sized twix so let's hope
that this was just some lesser astronaut
also named jameson
the daily globe eddie brock's old
employer the daily globe isn't just some
off-brand newspaper name
tossed into sony spiderverse within
comic book continuity the daily globe is
the very place eddie brock is fired from
after he messes up a story on the sin
eater while the globe is only mentioned
by name once over dinner it does come up
again later as eddie searches for work
one of the people he texts is barney
bushkin the publisher of the globe who
probably fired brock in the first place
for his crimes against journalism
bushkin carries a long-running grudge
against rival publisher jay jonah
jameson once even abducting him with a
robot and threatening him with a fake
gun in peter parker the spectacular
spider-man annual number one bushkin is
clearly not a guy to mess with
she's a lady once the name anne wayne
popped onto venom's cast of characters
symbiote enthusiasts the world over
wondered if she'd follow comic book
continuity and slip into something
slithery
she venom fans rejoice because anne
wayne does indeed briefly appear as a
female version of venom that's not a
good thing though
in the venom sinner takes all
mini-series the symbiote bonds with her
to save her life
but also takes her on an incredibly
violent killing spree eddie
ever supportive assures her that she was
probably more responsible than venom for
the mess
so by the time amazing spider-man number
two comes around the memory of the
experience is so traumatizing that she
climbs a building and leaps to her death
anne's reaction to chomping on someone's
head on the big screen
isn't much more than mild revulsion but
come on there are rockets to stop think
big picture
death by chocolate venom has a pretty
healthy appetite which includes tater
tots both frozen and burnt
trash chicken live lobsters and dogs and
human organs
so it may come as a small surprise when
venom asks for chocolate at the end of
the film but yes that's also from the
comics
in the venom the hunger miniseries
marvel's number one gloopy boy expresses
a distaste for normal human food and his
hunger for human brains awakens
it's not just a gritty 1990s comic book
choice it's science
the thing that the venom symbiote
actually craves from brains is
phenylethylamine a human
neurotransmitter
coincidentally that organic compound is
also found in
chocolate the compound also happens to
be in various types of shellfish so
those raw lobsters that he chowed down
on were a pretty good choice too
stan the man again it's no surprise that
stan lee makes one of his trademark
cameos and venom walking a small dog
near the end of the movie
stan is more or less a minor hero in the
mcu as well as the spider-verse keeping
children safe on school buses delivering
packages safely and even keeping casino
chips safe for easily distracted heroes
you know what i think i'll just take
these
bring them over here and hold on for
safekeeping
he's so great that he has stories to
tell the watchers who literally know
everything that ever happened and will
happen giving eddie brock advice on love
is just the most recent
of his heroic feats carnage of course
there's the in-credits appearance of
woody harrelson's cletus cassidy comic
fans already know that cassidy becomes
carnage a pretty violent villain and one
of many symbiotes in the marvel universe
whether or not a wandering symbiote
found its way into cassidy by the end of
venom is unclear though it stands to
reason that if something as wickedly
powerful as carnage was present cassidy
wouldn't be quietly sitting in a cell
the symbiote signature move
is having razor sharp blades for hands
after all those straps mean nothing